[Music]
everyone thanks for joining us my name
is Dario SH I'm the product manager for
Google's contact center AI is nice to
have you all here we have a jam-packed
agenda for you I'm gonna start by
telling you a little bit about what is
contact center AI and what is it good
for but most of the session will be
presented by by our partners right after
me
Josh will take the stage Josh is from
from my cell and he will show you how my
tell has integrated into the entire
Google contact center ai stack and how
they have used it to build a more
intelligent contact center after Josh we
will hear from offer offer is the
general manager for chat base chat base
is an area of 120 project within within
Google offer is going to talk about how
chat base complemented by contact center
AI can help you find call drivers call
topics and call intents in your in your
contact center locks Tracey will will
take this stage after that and Tracey is
going to tell you about how KPMG's
intelligent interactions platform work
suite contacts and Rai to optimize your
contact center operations and Andrea
from from Genesis will will wrap things
up by showing a nu / alternative a of
thinking about customer care channels
okay so with that let's talk a little
bit about contact center AI contact
center ai is part of a larger effort at
Google called Claudia in Claudia we
categorize our efforts into three
categories category number one is our
platform or AI platform which enables
machine learning engineers and data
scientists to run their machine learning
training prediction and analytics job
either in the cloud using cloud machine
learning engine or in a hybrid or even
on Prem environment using cube flow the
second category is are pre-trained
machine learning models easily
consumable through api's like our image
recognition object recognition models
translations model and natural language
model if you bring in your own label
data you can then customize this
pre-trained api for you for your use
cases using our auto ml technology and
I'm sure you have all seen a bunch of
announcements around Auto ml yesterday
and today the third category is our AI
solutions in the solutions category we
get these pre trained api's built new
pre train models and api's package them
together in a contained solution focus
on a set of very specific use cases and
contact center AI is one of those
solutions focused on customer care and
contact center use cases but how did we
get there we talked to a whole bunch of
customers and a lot of partners and they
told us a lot of pain points these pain
points fall into three distinct
categories category number one is the
infamous long and deep IVR three press
one to go left press two to go sharp
right press three to go slightly right
and I bet you none of you actually
enjoys that experience if you do please
do not raise your hand but anyone that
I've talked to it doesn't enjoy that
experience but once you actually push to
about seven times and three about six
times and along the way you provide your
account number a couple times and you
finally get to a live agent that agent
turns around and promptly asks you what
is your record number this information
that you provide the IVR at times gets
missed when the IVR transitions the call
to add to a live agent now that you have
provided your account number for the
third or end
time for that matter the Cajun probably
puts you on hold
unless you listen to some music while
the agent on the side is frantically
searching for the for the answer to your
your question this makes it for a very
poor color experience I don't think any
of us can the enjoys that experience but
it also makes it very very expensive to
operate the contact center when we talk
to our customers to our partners we
figured out that at some points in time
you know it takes up to about 15 bucks
to answer a call that actually comes to
a contact center that's a lot of money
for one call also the agents are being
are being pushed they need to find these
answers quickly their desktop is a mess
they have CRM they have contact center
they have search that results into
roughly about one out of three agents
churning within between twelve months of
joining a contact center it makes it
very very expensive to operate a contact
center so this is why we thought how can
we actually utilize AI to make this
experience better both for the color and
for the agent and that's why we build
contact center AI contact center AI has
three major components in it
the first one is virtual agent it is
based on our dialog flow enterprise
product in addition to automating the
transactional and common common
transactional and informational calls
dalek law allows you to flatten the IVR
three it allows you to replace press 1
for X + 2 for Y with hello I'm an
automated agent how can I help you today
and it can continue that conversation
with the color in a natural language
kind of a way it also has the ability to
raise the call directly to a to a human
human agent and it will make sure that
all the contacts gathered during the
call is actually passed from the
automated agent to the to the live agent
which brings us to the second bucket
agent assists
we built agent assists to make sure that
the experience for the live agents gets
better and more streamlined agent
assists as its name implies will assist
the agent by monitoring the call
building the context around that
conversation between that agent and that
customer will go to the knowledgebase
fetches the right answer or the right
article that has the answer in it and
surfaces it to their to the agent so
hopefully you will never again be put on
hold by an agent hopefully the third
piece is conversational topic not only
conversational topic modeling we'd allow
you to discover topics in your chat logs
and audio logs not only he will tell you
what topics your customers were calling
you about it will tell you which
keywords they use to articulate that
topic what were the top sentences they
use to talk about that topic I'm not
going to talk about topic modeling that
much right now because you will hear a
lot about it from from our partners by
the way whatever I have mentioned so far
and I use the term color it works both
for audio and phone as well as text text
and chat we will manage the session
between the contact center deployment
and all the AI is behind the scenes
everything is backed by a knowledge base
you can create multiple knowledge bases
to back your agent assist as well as
mutual agent by the way in this
color-coded slide Google builds the red
partner or the customer builds a green
that's that's what the colors mean I'm
not going to spend too much time going
to really texture right now due to time
but if you are interested in learning
more about the technical aspects of it
see me after after the session or see us
at the booth trust me we love to geek
out on this stuff we'll love to tell you
about it same thing with the topic
modeling CS and the mobile world all
chat about that contact center AI is
available in alpha exclusively through
through our partners today including our
I partners they are all fairly familiar
with our stack and can actually help you
on board on board onto it before I turn
it over to Josh to tell us about the
goodness of my tools contact center let
me make a shameless plug for another
session on CCAI that we have tomorrow
in this room at 11:40 we will see a lot
more demos about integrations into into
contact center AI we will see some today
about tomorrow we will see a lot more
integrations maybe even a couple of
people calling one another in the same
room so if you want to hear feedback -
audio feedback tomorrow is the best day
we also have sessions on speech-to-text
and electro enterprise which i think
they have occurred already so once you
actually got your hands on the videos I
encourage you to to check that out and
please please please go to cloud Google
calm like solutions back contact -
Center and obviously I got the font size
wrong please do not put that one on the
under under feedback but please go there
you will hear you will read a lot about
contact center moving parts but the most
important part is at the bottom of the
screen you need to scroll all the way
down there's a blue button that says I'm
interested click on it fill out that
form I will love to chat with you about
it with that I turn it over to Josh
well thank you Dario Sh I can't say how
excited we are to be here today working
with Google to really transform the
customer experience and deliver
something new something we call the
intelligent customer experience my tools
been in business for forty five years
and our focus is delivering seamless
communications and collaborations and
really helping businesses communicate
more effectively we have over 70 million
end users of our technology around the
world and we're number two in contact
center for total contact centers
deployed globally with more than 25
thousand businesses entrusting their
customer experience to Mitel solutions
you know our expectations are changing
and I'm sure you're aware of this just
as much as I am most of us want to
self-serve today we want to be able to
do through our app or on the website
find the information we're looking for
transact the way we want to transact and
we want that to be able to work on our
time on our schedule and from our device
and as a matter of fact synthetics has
identified that 90% of us will go to a
company's website before we'll call that
company so to me that means anytime
we're calling a company it's an
exception it's a missed opportunity for
a good customer experience and how
important is customer experience anyway
well Walker has identified that by 2020
customer experience will be more
important than product or price so it's
key that we figure out how to
reinnervation digitally transform our
businesses
let's take Tesla for instance they've
completely disrupted the auto ownership
experience and we know them all for
electric vehicles but did you know that
they can do over-the-air updates push
things like ludicrous speed or autopilot
after you've rolled the car out of the
dealership secondly they can do remote
diagnostics and they can roll a mobile
technician to your site to come do
repairs and service I would say it's
these things these longtail
differentiators that will in the end be
the brand that people know about Tesla
and they're way ahead on the technology
from
competition that's why we're reimagine
ating the customer experience to bring
that intelligent customer experience to
all the companies that use Mitel
solutions because we want them to be
able to transform their businesses as
well so we're combining Mitel's 45-year
history of understanding how businesses
communicate both with omni-channel
contact center and the way that we do
complex routing rules and combining that
with google's contact center cloud a I
the first is analytics so we do a lot of
context Center business and the key
thing that we typically do is focus
contact center metrics internally we
hope the business understand how
efficient their agents are you heard ere
you should say how expensive it is to
run a contact center that's why the
metrics are focused on keeping those
agents efficient but I would say that
with AI we need to start to look outward
it's not so much more about how do you
run efficient agents it's about how do
you take those exceptions when people
are calling into your contact center and
do something smart with it so the
ability to use topic modeler allows us
to take a look at the information about
why your customers are calling and help
you improve your products and solutions
the second is virtual agent if we all
want to self-serve then it makes sense
that an always-on agent that can get us
the answers that we're looking for would
be very helpful so with the virtual
agent capability from Google will able
to connect the customer directly to the
knowledge base inside the organization
this allows us to help that customer get
answers to their questions in real time
with the most up-to-date information
that's available to them and then of
course when we go to a live agent we
want to make sure that the customers
context of the conversation with the
virtual agent is maintained so we're
gonna pass that whole conversation to
the live agent make sure they understand
the context and then we're going to keep
the AI in the conversation to help coach
and do research for that agent in real
time now the same way that Google is
democratizing AI and bringing that to
all of us as enterprises Myto wants to
make sure that we can take the
capabilities of the context
components and bring them to all
verticals industries and make sure that
all size businesses can deploy this so
we've integrated it directly into our
cloud link platform it's a cloud born
native micro service architecture that's
global that allows us to securely
connect to the context centers that our
customers run either hosted and cloud or
in their on-site deployments so let's
talk about analytics for a second we
took a look at why our customers are
calling us so in the Mitel sales support
queue we ran more than 20,000 call
records through the top of modeler
engine and we took analysis on what was
coming in we identified when we had a
product launch we actually had a
migration licensing problem and we found
that through the signal here that you
see on the green line on the graph that
shows that we had upgraded software as a
high component for why people were
calling in now we were able to put a
migration fix in place and you can see
that green line trend down rather
rapidly after that was done this is how
we were able to improve our experience
for our resellers and for our customers
now we're working with other companies
to make sure that we validate this
technology we want to make sure that
it's simple deploy and easy to onboard
so a sentence ascend is travel is
helping us to work through some of this
and as a matter of fact
Rodney Patterson is here with us today
the CTO of ascend us and the key things
that he's excited about with using AI in
his business is how to personalize the
interactions for his customers enhance
support extending his hours and making
that interaction better and then
providing his advisors with a more
effective means to be very good in that
consultative vacation planning that they
do so without further ado let's go to a
demo
all right so I'm on the sentences
vacation website here and you'll notice
that there's many categories on their
website they've got great information
advisors that are experts in destination
for this luxury vacation travel
destinations that I can choose from
experiences they've even got a really
good blog that's very rich with content
the problem is as a customer I'm not
really sure where to start I'm not sure
what my vacation needs to be so I want
to talk to an advisor that can help me
through this so on their website I see
there's a number of different ways to
contact them I can come in through a
voice call I can email them but in this
case I want to do a live chat so I'm
gonna give them a little my information
here and while this is queuing up I'm
able to look a little the information on
the website make sure our internet
connections working smoothly here today
all right so now I'm greeted by Marisol
the ascendeth travel bot and Marisol can
help guide me through my preferences
experiences I'm looking for so in this
case I'm interested in a family vacation
and I think you know based upon my kids
age they like to go play at the beach so
maybe we'll go to Hawaii
now Marysol takes me through kind of an
understanding of my preferences and at
that time it's looking at what advisors
in the backend are available that can
help me with my consultative vacation
planning I think I'll just relax this
time all right so at this point Marisol
is going to give me to an agent that can
help me with this interaction it turns
out
Ahmed's the right person for me to talk
to so just like I mentioned we passed
the entire script of the bot interaction
with the customer right to the agent so
as Ahmed I can get the understanding of
the customers context where they want to
go who the customer is and at this point
I can say I'll help you with your
Hawaiian vacation travels oops Beckett I
all right so that we're staying in
stream right back and forth with the
customer saving the bot interaction and
now we'll see suggestions coming in so I
mentioned the I stays in the
conversation and we start feeding the
agent real information that's pertinent
to that conversation so the first
article that comes up here is Hawaiian
Islands travel for families which is
exactly what I had asked for so now I
can take a look at some of the ascenders
travel information I can see that Maui
is a good place for families that want
to relax a while who's a good place for
the classic Hawaii experience I think
Maui sounds good now at the same time as
an agent I can pass this information
right to the customer so that they can
look for themselves about that
information and they can be guided as
well all right so I'm going to go ahead
and in this interaction and we're going
to go into a voice interaction
hello thank you for calling us send us
vacations I'm Marisol the ascenders
travel but please tell me what type of
vacation you are looking for I want to
go to Europe do you know where you would
like to go no but I'd like to talk to
somebody that can give me some ideas no
problem we have expert advisors that can
help you find the perfect location are
you interested in a guided tour no
thanks
okay we would be delighted to help you
plan your vacation please hold on while
I pass you to one of our expert advisors
who can help you plan a fantastic trip
so at this point the call comes through
to the right agent that has expertise on
European vacation traveling and that
agent is handed a transcript of the
voice interaction between the bot and
the human and as we start getting into
this conversation we can actually expand
to provide suggestions the same way that
we did in chat
all right so a sentence is excited about
this opportunity if we can go back to
the presentation monitor thank you
they're really excited about being able
to focus on improving matching accuracy
for customers as they come to their
website and want to find that
consultative vacation they're also
wanting to increase the success rate of
first-time bookings and repeat bookings
come see more down at our booth in
Moscone West
13:23 thank you and at this point I'll
turn it over to Ophir hello how many
people here if they could do a project
and weeks would prefer that over months
just a show of hands okay the rest of
you maybe didn't hear the question so
chat base can help with just that teams
are building virtual agents for contact
centers can now save a ton of time so
we've heard about how topic modeling can
give you at a high level what calls and
live chats are belt well what we've done
is we've gone and that a very specific
use case level are able to map out the
flows of those conversations all that is
made possible by leveraging Google's
machine learning that's been developed
over many years we're within Google and
the same machine learning also powers
Google search parts of global search and
an assistant and Gmail so I'm excited to
say that today we're announcing our
early access program called chat base
Enterprise Edition which does just that
and and if you step back for the last
couple years we've been doing
optimization of optimization of virtual
agents and we've done that for hundreds
of thousands of virtual agents
processing billions of messages
to virtual agents and the new part that
we're announcing today is to help you
with insights for building these virtual
agents so normally when a team wants to
build a virtual agent for contact center
they get experts from within the company
into a room sometimes they bring in
consultants and they brainstorm what
should we build they might brainstorm
the flows they might think about how
many people phrase this and they might
come up with maybe 10 20 50 variations
but if you use data we've seen that you
can get thousands of variations and that
makes your buts you're a virtual agent
smart so really there's like three
shortcomings to this brainstorm approach
one is that you don't predict all the
nuances of the conversation all the edge
cases where conversation might go to is
that you miss trends in the contact
center whether it's seasonality new
products or other things like that it
just is hard to keep up with that and
and three third shortcoming is that it's
like a slow process very slow to flesh
out everything but really what it's all
about is that it's a black box what goes
on in the contact center how are people
or what are they calling what are people
calling about how do they phrase the
question is not always clear sometimes
they even say they don't even know what
their problem is you know they're trying
to figure it out what are good responses
by agents is always not very it's also
not always clear and so this is where
chat base comes in so we tagged all the
parts of the conversation actually at
the highest level we tagged what the
conversation is about this is a billing
example someone's calling to change
their bill due date and so we call it
the driver the highest level is billing
then 10th level is changed my bill due
date it's more specific and then we go
beyond that you see
the steps of that conversation you know
to what they do want to change it to and
then you know the customer provides the
new date so for each of these nodes we
extract thousands of variations for
example this is real data when someone
provides a new date you expect them to
just give a date right but we've seen in
the data people say how about between
the third and the fifth or the the mid
month on a Friday these are real
examples most virtual agents we like I
don't know what you know what you want
for me this is nothing wasn't trained
for this but if you use the data-driven
approach you can really handle all these
cases so I'm going to talk about the
three steps for building a data-driven
virtual agents it starts with
discovering what's in your data and then
you deploy it to production and then in
production you optimize the experiences
and we're gonna go into each one of
these so first step of the discovery
phase is to find what are the high level
drivers that people are calling in a
belt so we use unsupervised machine
learning also known as clustering to
give you a sense for what are the key
themes and and you can see here that
billing and accounts and returns are
major drivers but that tech support and
payment are not as common so let's go
for a second into the building and flesh
out up because it seems to be common so
we're then billing you see we've
clustered requests for changing billed
due date and that's a pretty big cluster
and then request for charges on your
bill or discounts to your bill are less
common at this stage we use some
supervised machine learning to clean up
the grouping but it's really the
unsupervised that gives you a sense of
where to look and what's important next
step is to go deeper into change bill
due date because it seems to be a large
intent within a large driver and so the
next step is to generate and this can be
done in a couple hours something we've
heard takes a week to four weeks you can
generate the detailed flow once that
intent is triggered change bill due date
you can see all the ways those
conversations go so in this case a
common flow is to verify the name then
what date and confirming the new date
each one of these nodes behind it has
the thousands of ways that it was said
you know and Google is one of the few
companies I understand language it's
been our business for a long time and so
it's a good technology to apply to this
problem okay so now we've we have the
building blocks for the virtual agent
and we've looked at it we verified that
looks good and it's time to deploy and
to deploy it to your virtual agent so
that's out there in the wild being used
by customers and then then you want to
optimize there's always going to be
things that you miss different things
that then show up in the original data
and so this is where you have a chance
to use the chat base not handle the
report it shows you all the cases where
the bot was I kind of know what the
customer is saying and here we again use
machine learning so in the case of let's
say my build timing won't work and get
paid on second so need a new due date
those weren't caught but with supervised
machine learning we suggest the intent
so we tell you this is what we believe
this should map to and with human review
can accept the whole thing if there's
ones that you're not sure about you can
bring up the full transcript to confirm
that it you know the context of it to
make sure it's appropriate after you've
gone through this step and the final
step is to check the funnel like are
people getting through this bill change
bill due date funnel for you know for a
specific intent check check
the funnel you can see there's a
drop-off not everyone gets through it
and here again you can bring up sample
transcripts to see why are people
dropping off and this is it could be a
customer experience issue and that will
come up in the transcripts so one large
enterprise that we've done this analysis
for shared that this way of building
virtual agents is like moving a 200
miles per hour compared to their
existing way which is 10 to 20 miles per
hour so it's like going from a horse and
carriage to a well-tuned race car anyone
that's interested in learning more about
this can come to the can visit chat base
and and and request a demo you can also
come by the contact center AI booth
where I'll be thank you next great tool
thank you thanks ever so as over said
contact centers are a bit of about black
box and and the the environment that
we're in today that's just not
acceptable because our call centers have
regulatory pressures on them that cost
us a ton of money and ultimately they're
the channel to our customers and the
reputational risk that we have if we're
not doing it right is just too too big
not to be doing something about it
so KPMG has been working with a lot of
customers to help them with their
contact centers and the broader customer
experience process and while we've been
doing a lot of topic modeling we've been
doing it more by our data scientists and
our engineers using more customized
tailored approaches so when Google gave
us the opportunity to test this new
topics topic modeling API we were
thrilled because we saw all the
opportunity in the world to take it to
our clients as a high accelerator to the
work that we've been doing and bring a
great amount of acceleration and
efficiency to some of the projects that
we could have done before and that we
will do in the future topic modeling
really is as we look at it
is the foundation of all of the the art
of the possible that you can do in the
contact center with artificial
intelligence and one of one of our lead
data scientists dr. Arthur Frankie
compares data to farming so instead of
data is the new oil data is the new soil
and topic modeling you can think of as a
key seed that will help you grow your AI
as you move into more AI enabled contact
centers so if we take a look at a more
end to end type of approach and one that
starts with topic modeling as this
foundational element we look at topic
modeling to drive out the topics that
are telling us what is happening in
these contact centers what are people
calling about what are the trends what
are the spikes
what is the seasonality and then we're
applying insight to them because once
you apply business insight operational
insight over what's happening in the
topic modeling you start to learn more
and more not just about your contact
centers but about your overall
organization and those things drive a
lot in in terms of value we divided into
these two buckets let's improve agents
and let's improve our actual
optimization the optimization that
happens from within the organization the
impacts that come from using artificial
intelligence in your contact centers so
let's take a look quickly at what we're
getting from the topic modeling itself
so you know at its root we're getting
increased insights we're understanding
the intense and the compound intents
that occur in these calls are in these
chat logs in order for us to really
understand what are the problems our
customers are experiencing are we able
to address those problems and when we
address those problems are they
satisfied it also enables us to take
that business oversight overlay it and
understand trends in the information so
where are my spikes where are my issues
where are my problems where as abnormal
or abnormality there we go
where's abnormality in what's happening
in my call centers and can I correct for
it and on the benefits side there's
there's really
a number of different things that that
can drive out of this so one of the
area's is eradication there's nothing
better to improve a call center then to
eradicate the conversation all together
if you understand that your customers
are having a specific problem that could
be solved by updating your website by
pushing alerts or notifications to them
by making it more obvious or improved
how they can answer that question using
one of their mobile channels and avoid
the call or the chat into the the
customer contact center altogether
that's the best outcome your customer
never had a problem that's good customer
experience and the cost doesn't exist
anymore because it's already been solved
and there's others as well so you know
feeding into agent training like like
over talked about in terms of being able
to build more virtually driven agents
and use the data to enhance it is is
imperative as well as a number of other
things so as I mentioned we were really
thrilled to be given the opportunity to
get our hands dirty using the topic
center that the topic modeling API and
what we did was we took 90,000 chat logs
from our own IT chat log from our own IT
Help Desk so the the data itself was
from the beginning of this year through
about June it had 90,000 chat logs in it
that involved about 67 agents and about
23,000 unique users so it was a pretty
pretty pretty significant sized data set
and out of that data set when we ran the
topic modeling API over it we came out
with about a hundred core topics that
emerged from those those chat log
conversations that we then clustered
down to about 50 ish and as we did this
we began analyzing the output what can
we learn from this there's two examples
of what we found
first as we looked at a month-over-month
analysis and when we did this we found
some interesting facts that our own
helpdesk didn't really have readily
identified
as specific issues that potentially
could be resolved either a by improving
a process and therefore eradicating they
need all together or using some more
advanced methods like like being able to
apply dialogue flow to use some some
more automated approaches to responses
the first was there was a spike in
people requesting RSA token password
resets and the spike happened right
around audit busy season well that's
because the auditors are in the office
until busy season hits and then once
busy season hits they're out at client
sites so they haven't used their RSA
token in a month or two they forget
their password they have to get it reset
before they go back out to the client
sites so that they can VPN in to that
work well for us this is an opportunity
to automatically do pre notifications
let's look at all of our auditors that
haven't used their VPN in the past four
weeks or six weeks and let's push them a
note with a link that says if you need
to reset your password do it here
eradicate the calls altogether another
interesting piece of analysis that we
did was we looked at the median agent
chat word length compared to the length
of the chat as well as the number of
turns in each chat so how much
back-and-forth was occurring in each
chat along with the total volume of the
chats that had occurred in each one of
the topics we found a couple interesting
things so one of them was that if you
look at software installation as a topic
area and compare it against conference
call information you'll see that
answering these chats took about the
same amount of words but look at how
much longer it takes for the software
installation questions to be answered
properly and the difference there is for
the software installation topics the
agent had to go and do some research
they had to go and get some information
they had to go and get the right type of
response to give them there were no
templates there was no ready information
available for them to give to the
customers when we look at conference
Skol it was copy-paste done it's the
same amount of words but a lot a lot
loved a lot of increased length so
conference calls that is an immediate
low-hanging fruit ready for for the
application of dialogue flow to get
automated I don't need to be answering
that with a human anymore it's already
template and it's ready to go on a
software installation side I'm looking
at this thing well gee if I had an agent
assist that was saying I heard them ask
about their time and expense here's the
information they need to upgrade their
time and expense so opportunities for
improvement were apparent right from the
very beginning even by just doing some
very basic analysis but where do we go
from here so in moving this forward the
the real power of topic modeling as I
mentioned is that topic modeling is that
foundation it's that seed that we can
grow into something else and by
overlaying a lot of of the application
of analytics over this we're able to
actually do some real steady-state run
operations in improving the way that
we're serving our internal customers so
one of those ways is turning this into
real monitoring so if I have my topic
modeling occurring over my customer
channels on an ongoing basis then I can
monitor what's spiking what's what are
the issues that are coming up what are
the issues that I put a process
improvement in place for because it was
a spike and can I monitor that it's a
that it's being eradicated that it's
dropping off and one of the other areas
is in active programs so we all have a
lot of change in our organization's
we're getting a new tool or a new
technology or a new upgrade or a
migrating to an operating system all the
time and these programs spike the need
for customer service the need for the
address meant of questions and issues
and one of those areas that we recently
had was we implemented a new tne system
and we knew that there was going to be a
spike of information a spike of need for
call answering when we we were
implementing this new system but what
they didn't readily know was what
or the very specific issues people were
having problems with how can we improve
the training for the next round of
deployment to make sure that people
don't have to call about those things
what are the but active bugs in the
system that are spiking that maybe just
hadn't been contemplated in the initial
implementation that we can again prepare
to eradicate for in the next the next
round of deployment and so some of the
things that we found were double gate
access everyone was having there was a
huge spike in people not being able to
identify how to delegate to other
individuals to handle their Tanny they
were having trouble uploading their
expenses their expense expense receipts
where those were required they were also
having issues in the replication of
their old profile to the new profile so
some of these like delicate access is
better fa Q's better better information
available better training for the next
rollout process improvement some of the
others were issues with the technology
that either needed improvement or had
bugs than them that needed to be fixed
but we're able to monitor them now in a
way that we know something real is
happening and that it needs to be
addressed so with that please visit us
right outside this door at the KPMG
booth we'd love to talk to you more
about this and I'm going to hand it over
to Andrea from Genesis who's going to
take us to the next piece
hello good morning it's a pleasure to be
with you
probably you noted that that wasn't my
picture in the presentation for a very
simple reason you were probably
expecting it with Andrea nice Italian
lady the nice Italian lady it's me sorry
about that
we start with the bad news but let's
start instead with good news so first I
want to present very quickly my company
if somebody is not terrible familiar
with Genesis awfully you saw our main
stage demo I want and if you can
broadcast please my my phone so Genesis
is a living solution provider of
customer experience platforms we have we
enjoyed this living living role that is
recognized by our analysts
so Forrester will be nominated 23 times
in a row in the channel Magic Quadrant
and we have a similar appreciation by
the analysts like Forrester and ovum but
especially we enjoy the trust of 11,000
customers in 100 countries and we manage
for them 25 billion interaction period
those are meaningful interaction those
are the interaction of the top if you
take the top 100 brands in the world 65
of them are Genesis customer so that's
what we are so I now remove my hat as a
sales person to become a Technical Sales
I want to show you a new channel that we
want to leverage thanks to the
partnership with Google I want to show
you an application that we built in
combination with Google ok let's see on
the screen I want to talk with Genesis
Kate all right getting the test version
of Genesis Kate greetings this is Kate
what can I help with search what should
I do if I plan to travel internationally
to prevent an interruption in credit
card access it's necessary to set a
travel alert on the credit cards you
plan to use while traveling you can set
a travel alert using online banking by
calling the number on the back of your
card or by talking to G Bank automated
agent on your Google home device we just
saw this is a new channel so I'm a
customer of a bank G Bank actually I'm
at the banker of G Bank of Genesis but
there was a customer they wanted to
interact with its own Bank
imagine yourself for a second as a
consumer if you want to talk with your
bank your insurance what you do what you
want the web you search for a phone
number most of the time when you dial
there is no clue who they are or if you
are really good if they are really good
they know thanks to the your number that
you're calling who you are have not idea
what is the intent of your call in this
particular case I just asked a Tulpa
Jerry skater
magically I could ask whatever question
in a natural language integration no
flow no strict guided flow in that in
the DOS terrible idea that's pretty cool
let's see something else so it's asking
to explore the $10.00 talk to Genesis
Kate talk to Genesis Kate okay let's get
the test version of Genesis Kate
greetings this is Kate what can I help
with what is exactly trouble a lot a
travel alert allows the bank to allow
transactions from a foreign country
this helps to avoid false fraud alerts
this is exactly what they need so give
up what country are you going to I want
to go to France to provide better
service I'll just need to get your name
and Street
address from google is that okay yeah
travel alert for France has been set no
distant what is happening there we get
to the confirmation that something has
been happening do you understand why
this is a new channel he is a computer
completely new game immediately I don't
have to declare when I can do the
conversation and when there is
information that is critical is privacy
sense immediately what happens Google
asked the permission to pass this
information to the stake to the stack
the juristic so privacy is completely
granted to your customer and at the same
time we are giving an incredible service
so and of course you noted probably also
that we you probably noted that we
received an SMS of course because it was
an action that was he could offer an
actual a back-office process that is set
up the alert for the customer in this
particular case we see there alyx travel
alert for France has been set that's
great that was gate do you know the G
Bank offers insurance for trip abroad
that's fantastic just ask Kate to
schedule a callback not difficult at all
right so at this point let's invoke one
more time Kate
I want to polka Genesis gate okay let's
get the test version of Genesis Kate
hello this is Kate what can I help with
call me back to provide better service
I'll just need to get your name and
street address from Google is that okay
yeah calling you right away to come on
the stage my colleague Joseph shoe for
if you can put on one screen the agent I
want to stress what up in one more time
we posted information with the customer
is the platform
laughter bed to the grant has been given
by Google immediately we can call back
the custom without asking and request
you which phone where should I call you
that has been posted automatically
thanks to the Google API at this point
the call will be served by an agent so
if we have Joe on the screen as soon its
market ready I will get the call back
and the dialogue of course I will put on
the caller ID now at this point of
course let me after my microphone now
the dialogue assistant that you saw on
the screen can start so I hope that you
enjoyed has enjoyed this presentation
this is definitely the new face of the
customer experience back to you
Thank You Andrea offer Tracy and Josh
appreciate it and please a round of
applause for the sound and video crew so
this clock tells me that I have zero
minutes left we'd be happy to take your
questions but we are getting kicked out
of this room so we will meet you outside
we'd be happy to chat with you and with
that thanks so much everyone
[Music]